today I'll show we finally talked about
Batman ish right we're gonna show you
some DC movie universe news that's
happening right now we're going to talk
about it right now still developing on
fat man on Batman this is I'm brewing it
up man iron the butter you know that
would be chairing the button ah dad
[Music]
welcome the fat man of Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Oprah Norton
let's dive into it last week mark yes
Gotham City sirens wasn't it was
announced they're talking about doing a
movie that this was the Harley Quinn
spin-off solo movie that they were
talking about right before Suicide Squad
came out and so it's morphed now into
clearly a Harley Quinn movie but they're
Gotham City sirens means that they're
bringing in Catwoman
indeed who they've yet to cast that's
exciting totally and poison ivy poison
ivy you they've yet to cast so they're
gonna expand their DC Universe Margot
Robbie Robbie mm-hmm comes AG either one
you see the Robie yeah yeah rapid mallet
in hand to be in this movie is directed
by same guy who directed Suicide Squad
my friend David Eyre air yes we're not
that good friends I can't but my god
[ __ ] that that's exciting news we
didn't think we were ever gonna see like
I don't know I'm never in a million
years thought we'd see a Gotham City
sirens movie I mean I was kind of hoping
for her mad love I was kind of hoping
that that would have been the Harley
Quinn spin-off that should have gotten
yeah you know I think I mean look I
don't know [ __ ] from [ __ ] but didn't
seem like they were wildly thrilled
about their Joker no no but I think that
that's one seemed like he was wildly
thrilled about what happened to his
Joker there's that too so I wonder if
this just I mean I feel like they're
gonna lip service to Joker and then it's
you know girls night out in Gotham doing
crime and [ __ ] and when he says Harley
lip services the Joker he doesn't mean
in that dirty way no none of that
yeah they're probably even mad a bit or
just like Oh mr. J and maybe a pop I
don't know how did they [ __ ] into a
Harlequin movie don't bring the Joker
back even for a second I mean that's
what mad low was great about was that it
was so much about being the like getting
out from under an abusive relationship
and finding your girl and hitting the
road and like no [ __ ] at all given for
anybody which you can still kind of do
here like there's no reason you don't
have that spirit in this thing but you
know part of me just wanted here's
here's the string the hook you ready for
this
easy these are doubling down
on the female card in a way that the
Marvel movies have yet to do they've had
you know strong females in the movie but
it's baffling why black widow hasn't had
her own standalone movie but they got
Captain Marvel coming they do before yet
but it's it is funny that as far ahead
of this if you're racing these two
particular horses believe me neither
company is racing each other no more
really don't give a [ __ ] about each
other except that Marvel is pretty sure
they win and DC is playing catch-up and
they all sort of know this but even
still the one place where DC seems to be
winning is getting female characters on
screen and giving female characters
their own movies we're gonna get Wonder
Woman first yeah and then it's gonna be
followed by Gotham City sirens which is
a pretty female heavy flick I mean
they'll be dudes in it like they've got
their Commissioner Gordon Gotham City
implies that yeah maybe the bat shows up
and if he doesn't come in he's gonna get
bucked in the mouth it could be but you
know they're building their universe and
playing bats gotta show up I mean they
really like most of your work in that
you know even if they did what they did
in Suicide Squad like that dude on a
roof of a car I wasn't Ben that was a
stunt guy Ben was the guy who takes off
the breather yeah Ben wasn't even the
guy that got punched in the war you know
what I'm saying so thanks there for a
day and a half at best in and out so you
know they can that way then they throw
to stop guy into the suit and go apeshit
let him do a bunch of things because
you're looking for Batman you ain't
looking for Ben Affleck at that point
you know and four key moments you give
Ben Affleck and that's my guess I have
no [ __ ] clue I've no connection some
people like he knows Ben Affleck not
anymore
sure of us Ben Affleck like hey boy
how's Kevin Smith these days he'd be
like I don't watch King of Queens
why would I so that being said let's
segue from Gotham City Cyrus to batfleck
himself indeed because Entertainment
Weekly good folks Entertainment Weekly
who used to employ I am a loner Timmy
week that's right yeah we have to say
that put that disclaimer boilerplate
before people write in your book and
shook in that [ __ ] thing's dick
that's all we do on this show this is
nothing things dicks yes so get used to
it
Batman I'm Batman on things
yeah if you're looking for some hey
[ __ ] find it out there's a plenty
Internet there's like 99.9 there's a
real estate out there where people just
hate on [ __ ] but here have to cradle the
balls and we're so that all being said
yes Entertainment Weekly gave us this
new image from Justice League the movie
that Zack Snyder is he's done shooting
no yeah so they're cutting right now
when's it come out no fall fall of 2017
yes fall over really yeah so they're
gonna go before Star Wars Wonder Woman
is their summer Sony yeah that's on me
listen by the way these are all off my
memory which has been proven to be less
than reliable at times yeah every once
in a while I see people be like you
[ __ ] idiot yeah because I don't have
the internet my disposal while you're on
the internet I occasionally that's
Marc's way of saying I'm a middle-aged
man some [ __ ] I just don't get right
used to keep the numbers up here yeah
not so much anymore okay so the notion
here is damn mmm there you got three
members of the Justice League together I
mean there's another Trinity it's not
the Trinity of course cuz Superman's
missing missing although we know he's in
this movie right you just saw the black
suit design pictures but there's flash
standing next to Batman standing next to
Wonder Woman looks like she wearing
booty shorts but I think those are
leathering I think so cop it's supposed
to be like a baby skirt yeah that makes
more sense than like just the [ __ ]
bikini yeah look at my Brazilian look at
my landing strip for my invisible jet
be miss Kay that looks like her shield
at her feet mm-hmm now there's a
description come along with the picture
says this is in a space in Gotham City
mm-hmm where there is a nest get ready
there's the exciting part why they
didn't include this [ __ ] in the photo I
don't know a nest of parademons well now
they told us that Steppenwolf is the
villain of this piece but I call
[ __ ] I think Steppenwolf is a
villain of this piece man I think we're
getting evil I think we're gettin dark
sides
Wow and I think they've been keeping it
[ __ ] quiet like the same way we
didn't know we were getting [ __ ]
doomsday until they drop that trailer
and you were like oh my god they're
doing doomsday - I think they're [ __ ]
I think I think Darkseid's in this now
see where do they where do they ratchet
up - if they're doing Darkseid right who
gives a [ __ ] I'm just curious
[ __ ] suspended leave it alone at the
table won't Empire bill just make an
amazing [ __ ] one-off movie and then
worry about the sequel later on or the
empire building but [ __ ] you put
Darkseid into the Justice League movie
that's who they're [ __ ] fighting
because they said it was gonna be to
Justice League movies right and now
they're saying it's one Justice League
movie so don't build to him just [ __ ]
give me some Darkseid son you do that
I'm a happy camper
look I'll probably like it even without
Darkseid yeah but it can't just be
Steppenwolf like come on like yeah that
would be a bit sad you know what I'm
saying like he's not saying he's a
terrible character but he's a pawn he's
the [ __ ] dude before the dude so in a
world where they say parademons they
also say in order to get to this nest
there's a Batman Spider vehicle that
could climb walls like a I don't know
the way they described it to me sounded
like a toy yes we need to sell the toys
essentially but no one I'd ever seen in
the Batman books the way they described
it but it's a cool ass vehicle that
they're using so I don't know man there
you go in Flash's armor I don't
understand the logic of this like it
looks like the red pieces are armored
and the black is just an under bodysuit
so why is he only armoring some parts
like not my nipples no nip slips and
also if you're fast enough to outrun
speeding bullets why do you need armor
I'm just well I mean his thing is a car
let's be real you're fast you know if
you if you're as fast as him and a bee
hits you in the [ __ ] face you'd the
be--would might go through you you know
I'm saying are you through the be like
yes but doesn't these bugs like the wave
car windshields and bugs
yeah but as mouths wide open there's a
writer right there I could only take the
logic so far guys but hey whatever it's
again
toys there's a flash outfit I mean we're
all used to really [ __ ] awesome flash
outfit from TV yeah for some reason they
feel the need
to differentiate so there may be maybes
flash from another time in this medieval
flashing we don't know it yet
it may maybe it'll make sense but we've
seen the outfit mm-hmm and Suicide Squad
yep
but yeah I don't understand the
patchwork armor but whatever [ __ ] I like
his portrayal and the [ __ ] trailer of
Justice League what's his name yeah Ezra
Miller
he's got me man like and I was the it
was tough to get me because I love
[ __ ] Grant Gustin but he did
something with his character in the
trailer where I was like you know what
that's interesting I'll check that out
so we're gonna get the movie in which
Batman builds arm of her flash right cuz
that's the whole thing like Ygritte
shows up a flashes lair that's the the
first trailer that we saw oh yeah that
would make sense and so he built him
that armor and Tony Stark builds
spider-man a badass real [ __ ] suit
yeah because I guess Batman is like you
read more armor this is gonna be
Batman's outfit there's almost no
greyscale left it's black on black on
black but I'm ready
my body's ready to receive this [ __ ]
movie I do I do still have that fond
memories of the Dark Knight Returns like
what do you think I put a giant [ __ ]
target on my chest which means maybe
we'll get to that
mmm fingers crossed yeah maybe maybe in
the next bet maybe that's what I should
see if I'm Affleck and I'm making my
Batman movie one day mmm big flat out
[ __ ] Bulbul yellow back yeah that'd
be bad
nobody's ever have they ever done that
straight up like closest was Batman you
know and Batman Returns there was yellow
in the bat there but ever since Nolan
it's been a black bat yeah and then Zack
Snyder black bat if I'm Affleck just
give it the simple [ __ ] it
oh well get as close as possible to the
iconic version of it everyone's gonna
know from the director Argo [ __ ] me oh
and there's new movies got I saw a
billboard for Bob stirs my famous
respected kombu ever made probably I
thought Tommy steps up to bat yeah I
don't know how
the other oscar-winning directors have
made superhero movies he didn't win an
Oscar for being a director though true
but he's is that Oscar winner as
producer and double do two times he's
also writer oscar-winning writer
producer excellent point
excellent point could you imagine he
wins is directing Oscar with Batman that
would be a magic trick then the bars I
get after man we work together what's
there it is folks wait one more thing is
one more thing that's right in DC
Universe movie news this is kind of dope
yes James Wan directing Aquaman
directing Aquaman yes we know who's
playing Aquaman mm-hmm Jason Momoa is
playing and we've seen him in the
trailer with the [ __ ] ocean head in
the man [ __ ] like throwing the bottle
looking like the most metal Aquaman ever
made now those that know the comics know
that Aquaman's half-brother is named arm
Aurum ocean master they've picked their
villain for the Aquaman movie and it's
[ __ ] ocean master and it's going to
be played by Patrick Wilson yes the guy
who played night owl in Watchmen and
he's was in the conjuring movie instead
with James Bond directed now you see
it's all [ __ ] - you know I wish I
knew James Wan maybe you can call me
James Wan um this is dope man like
number one I like that guy's good actor
he's very good he's got countable bona
fides because of Watchmen but I'm gonna
say it again
ocean master they better give him that
[ __ ] goofy ass face mask and [ __ ]
like that what a cape and a [ __ ]
tried and sure I just I wanted black
mantas Black Manta Manta he's God this
was Carl Laemmle on the TV show yes ma
a.m. t is at the dots in there with the
dots there was a time where that was as
close as we got to comic book anything
and we'd be like wow I mean he's wearing
a mask but he went on to be the voice of
Martian Manhunter
yes so while he was John Jones he's got
a great voice a voice okay wait how do
we get to Longley uh I was talking about
how I wanted
Manta all roads lead to lovely Black
Manta go Wow yeah I've look [ __ ] I
want Black Manta more than ocean master
I was just blown away they went for
ocean master we get both I didn't say
that they haven't that it's not both
like look if I'm them
I ain't saving anything no you're gonna
get one of these anything I'm putting in
[ __ ] Black Manta ocean master chicken
of the sea Charley do anything you ever
saw the incredible mr. limpet anything
you ever saw under we got Nemo can we
get Nemo and on crack in like it's kind
of me dude
it's an Aquaman movie so it's like dump
leave it all on the ocean floor don't
save anything give me and master an
Black Manta and mirrors in it we know
yeah [ __ ] Justice League as that
picture of mirror coming out the water
warm warm there it is ocean master man
Patrick Wilson well that's exciting
[ __ ] DC Universe movie news man's get
more and more exciting yeah do you have
people who that favorite you might want
to play Catwoman and poison ivy if you
have to dreamcast and we're casting out
of I mean I don't know like if I'm
[ __ ] Warner Brothers yeah I'm thrown
I'm I'm loading up a money cannon firing
it into the face of Jennifer Lawrence mm
who puts out passengers whose is that
that is uh Sony it's not Warner Bros I'm
Warner Brothers man she's done playing
mystique Yoshi's rumor you know remember
in the legend I don't you've done but
she said in the last one
they'd have to [ __ ] pay a lot of us a
lot of money do this again because like
get a beer a ninth mystique film mm-hmm
uh but ever who don't like jail aw
that's true so I load up all of loan up
a tommy gun full of [ __ ] Gatling gun
whatever [ __ ] did it
so just plowed her in a face with
[ __ ] money until she was like yes
I'll be Catwoman or poison ivy either a
[ __ ] one pick one you if I if I had
my druthers
okay I would want Emma Watson and I want
Hermione and it is poison ivy
it's so funny literally at Talking movie
names because I was like remaining as
Catwoman that's poison
that's poison ivy and I won ruth negga
as Catwoman I'd go with that she's
[ __ ] on preachers turn she's in that
was the loving movie she's great he's
tremendous
yeah and that character like she does a
lot with that character characters
[ __ ] boiling and big as [ __ ] on
preacher yeah that's a good car but
Gemma Jayla is [ __ ] poison ivy what
else she loves pretty money that's all
that is and she's good actress he's very
good actually talked to great actors
this be honest but at that point like if
I'm Warner Brothers I'm working I'm if
I'm Warner Brothers I always try to do
everything like [ __ ] Marvel Studios
but I would definitely take the steel
the playbook for Marvel Studios going
like there are no stars here these
characters are the stars I don't think
that's the case with buck Fleck I think
they're paying in a lot of money I don't
think he's doing it cuz it's a car just
like that man nope I think the fan but
Marvel's game seems to be like they have
to pay the ones that stick around for a
while like Robert Downey jr. is getting
paid Sonny Aldo for charity but yeah the
characters are the stars and you'll see
that as everyone starts to age out as
well the day that you know we don't want
to see this day ever happen but the day
that Robert Downey jr. is no longer Tony
Stark and someone else is you will feel
like we felt when we saw you know
[ __ ] who's the young Han Solo now
Alden Ehrenreich Oh Jon give him a shot
go man I'm all for it but in a world in
which we've all had like eight James
Bond's yeah and [ __ ] six Batman's
yeah at this point yeah all right maybe
mmm so yeah we're used to change you
kids aren't though wait till it happens
to you I mean that's that's how
characters achieve immortality by being
recast I mean if we can get another
Captain Kirk you can get on the Tony
Stark um I like your idea that's a good
idea in there now she's so it's a really
good idea there it is folks
[ __ ] we've we've stunt casted
nobody's asking us know but they want to
though they should call us try things or
anybody like and I picked the Jade the
Jennifer Lawrence thing just because I
was trying to think like a studio head
but is there an actress that I would
like you know who I would you know I'm
like Genesis robbery goes a lot I'll see
my Rosario
if he could if you could break her out
of muggle yeah that's the thing it's a
marvel oil just like I was gonna say zoe
saldana but she's powerful oil and stuff
you know some cats will never walk
between two worlds no you know they're
there Marvel true and then like that was
there only gonna make 96 more of those
Guardians let her go to the DC Universe
but it resented be a good cat woman I
would watch that yeah there was error be
good anything yes it's been good [ __ ]
Batman that's how good she is an actress
right you guys suddenly you're like I
want to see Batman with rosario Dawson
is Bruce Wayne and Batman and [ __ ] this
is bad woman yeah they can do that yeah
she's like I'll need your DC gig well
she is what was she what is the [ __ ] is
she a voice in something she was Wonder
Woman in the animated in the ANA yeah
she wasn't one of them she was like a
sister or something like that mess no
cuz Wonder Woman I thought was Felicity
felicity but I think I thought there was
one of them in which she did play Wonder
Woman yeah maybe she's in Justice League
dark don't maybe I don't know um I don't
know if she's true blue Comic Sans
all right so there it is nothing but
[ __ ] love good news from the DC
Universe movie front getting ever closer
this Justice League picture which um I'm
gonna but money right here's $20 right
there says that it's dark side your bad
guy
nice forgotten s2 parademons dark sides
next I mean we did see the big Omega
I'm in the middle of Batman V Superman
exactly exactly it's coming most logical
reason right there yes there it is folks
were stoked for these DC movies but
nothing nothing Batman we finally talked
about Batman on fat man I'm Matt I'm
mark barnard come back watch another
episode sometime later on same fat John
same bat-channel faction this is about
chimes bat-time same bat-channel
punk-ass cop or youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith
[Music]
you